The joe rogan experience,
you pull it through as
you push it through.
It's like there's no,
there's no banging on my wrist at all.
I don't feel anything on my right one,
it's on my left.
It's just a timing thing.
It's like as it's coming up like you'd
get into here and then all in one motion.
You should it like this where your hand
quote meaning you're doing swing swings
is a different thing.
Yeah.
If you want to do,
when you're doing two
hand cleans up twice.
If you go on to him cleans,
you'd have one in each arm and you go
like this like that you recommended?
I do.
The ones I like,
I like to him to this,
it makes me work both sides the same,
what's it called?
It's called project tango and it's been
out for a little while but they made
some adjustments for the sake of io
and it's a a tablet if it looks like a
regular tablet,
but what it actually has the ability to
do is to map three d space in real time.
So if you think of like VR generally
you put on a Vr headset and you're in
whatever university
they want to put you in.
This one is looking at the actual thing.
So interacting with objects is something
you can still do even though you're
looking at a digital representation of it.
You know what I'm saying?
Sounds,
sounds weird,
but like a couch,
it's still a couch.
So you could,
you could like almost stylize it and
say you can put like an alligator on the
couch next to you,
for example,
like a completely active scenario
that you can interact with physically.
And on top of that they have,
um,
the other use case scenario that I
think they're talking about is like in
mapping projects,
mapping internal spaces
and things like that.
But it's in a developer mode right now.
So you can either hold it
up and do it like that.
Uh,
normally.
And they also build like a actual
physical headset for would be wicked for
greenscreen gps where you could
actually have gps and going in between.
But the,
the main,
uh,
one of the main propositions just for
robotics because right now robots don't
see very well and this would essentially
give robots the ability to see time and
space similar.
Shoot the whole
thing off the host talking about 280
blower.
It's small.
It's a tight arrow.
That's her small
aluminum and carbon.
I thought you like the iPhone.
Awesome.
Wow.
Yeah,
it
will be old one.
It fits.
Ooh,
that's,
that's clean.
That was all right.
I hit a nice sweet spot.
I have this awesome
background on the gang green.
Yeah,
that's on target and I'm all set.
That's on target.
It's just a matter of
these things when we don't,
but we'll book.
That's good.
Cut it
sharp or is it like a point?
There's a point.
Yeah.
It's definitely a point.
Do we want to try and get this done?
We need to do,
I should
bring it up here.
Bring Nafa said,
oh,
get here.
I guess.
All right.
Here we're going to
need the big boat book.
Said it a little easier to manage a
swap your main just to 10 pounds more
pulling.
No,
it's 100% not necessary and we're
actually going to shoot those thing.
I'll explain what this
is and what of those and
yeah,
it's a lot like,
oh,
like if you wanted to do this,
if you want to do this experiment,
this is,
no,
if not,
you know the other one that I to is
the most powerful compound bullet point
stuff.
You have to order it
special from the factory.
Like you can't even
buy this from the most.
You can buy a running count
along from a low score,
but there will be more on like this
is a special order.
The 90 [inaudible],
the other one
got called at nine.
It's called point factor to 90 pounds.
Draw weight.
It shoots 490 green arrows.
288 is one of the most
powerful pose known to man.
It's like you could conceivably
make something that's more powerful.
Like I've heard of a hundred
pound bows but very few companies.
Or is this data?
This is all about the distance.
This is all,
um,
this one doesn't have a sight tape on it.
If you look at this one,
see site
a little more.
Last lap,
the CEPHEID.
Oh,
smell the burn.
It's barbecue barbecue.
It'd be smelly arrowhead springs.
She's scholastic.
Oh Shit.
Yeah.
That's fresh smelling.
Burning plastics by aluminum
and it's very smallest diameter,
but very heavy in weight and because of
that it penetrates deep into the target.
Do Lowe's through phones.
It's,
that's right.
Can you get that on Amazon prime?
Right
excessively went through my pops.
I mean,
rolling.
You're rolling on that one.
Rolling.
Right now there's a little price,
so it's time to do the real deal.
Now we have the Sapphire glass.
We're going to a teeth bay
over top of the target.
You
Bullseye.
Bulls-Eye.
Kapow.
There we go.
This one,
it was scared of flip back.
The only thing I'm worried about is you
guys the dark glasses on nominate depth
behind it.
Okay.
Yeah,
I think.
exactly.
You finished chatter.
You,
here's what they can
somebody get a sip thumbnail.
You need to just that.
Oh,
right over top.
The
right there.
Excuse me.
Yeah.
You know what I'm saying,
dude?
Okay.
Yeah.
I'm going to say,
okay.
I'm at full draw and then you hit the
button and then I'm going to wait three
and shoot.
Is it boys right now?
I think when we,
I had one in one shot.
All right,
here's full dry.
Are we going to have
more than one shot at it?
What are you talking about?
US.
All right,
go ahead and anytime you're ready.
Go.
Definitely that didn't work.
Yes sir.
That's the one
right there
by the table
in a pretty good accuracy and needs
further fruit.
The next phone,
iPhone still be shit
out here in the range.
Next came the real world
to love as well.
Oh
now it's time to show
Samsung some love as well.
We get John from Tlv and you said
you're not a partial only that let,
we got to spread the love
and why are we doing that?
Oversight and Terry as chair,
we need,
we need t shirts that say for
science this flavor but chuck taping.
Yeah,
you guys could just,
you know what you should do?
You should try to have that video going.
If that phone works,
have a video going of the Arrow coming
out and just blackness or quick,
wow,
that's pretty cool
right now.
It is my glow.
You know what?
I might go that sizzling.
Right?
So
we should again,
probably
military
more comparative
screen than the Hundred
Years War shooting.
When you see it go.
All right,
we're ready.
Let's do it.
Full drill,
baby
drill
a little
better than that.
I would say it held up a little better.
That's
it.
[inaudible].